typhoid pretty sure that's when you get
like a knuckle in your knee I have not
taken the SAT before I took the ACP I've
done prep for both the SAT and the a CT
I have never taken a nicety
but in high school my junior year I did
take the a CT I took the SAT once got a
1100 on it you know 1945 I don't know
eighteen twelve thirteen twenty four 400
BC there's gonna be questions about like
like shoveling and like raising cattle
or something I dealer bought a lot of
three horses and some mules for $600 he
sold a lot for 820 if he gained $40 on
each horse and $50 for each meal how
many meals were there I feel like this
would be the type of question that
people would make fun of it just post
means about it I could maybe see this in
a third grade math problem to be quite
honest I don't know like what a
reasonable price for three horses and
some meals are two mules is my final
answer
two of those were meals I thought this
is tricky premise there are 12 months in
the year but Washington and Lincoln were
born in the same month February
conclusion the two greatest Americans of
the next 200 years will be born in
February there Washington and Lincoln
you know people knew their birthdays but
today I knew even though they were born
in February there's a lot of great
people in history I know like Martin
Luther King jr. Obama Gandhi Oh a bit
East North American probably follows
probably false is when I think in
February today I'm thinking Martin
Luther King the statement that the moon
is made of green cheese is absurd
misleading improbable unfair or wicked
it does green cheese even exist
gonna throw like blue cheese that's a
real cheese first of all why would this
be on the SAT what knowledge is this
gonna like enhance improbable it's a
weird word choice maybe it was used a
lot back in the day no Hans that's a
wicked Cal you got on the field I will
in absurd a flight they go hand in hand
but because you're in high school I
that you know the moon is not made of
green cheese if a package containing 20
cigarettes costs 15 cents how many
cigarettes can be bought or ninety cents
this has to be back in nineteen twenty
something the cigarettes are definitely
costing way more than fifteen cents
those question would definitely not make
it onto the real SATs so a hundred
twenty cigarettes is my answer you would
have to buy four cigarettes with sixteen
cigarettes left really oh okay
if a man's salary is twenty dollars a
week and he spends 14 dollars a week how
long will it take him to save $300 I
mean I guess it depends how old he is
because if I was making twenty dollars
oh no wait no I don't want to be making
twenty dollars sweetie what can you buy
for six dollars a pack of gum there's
not even a man it has to be a kid
probably doing chores my final answer is
forty two weeks on a couple days fifty
weeks
don't SAT lessons have multiple choice
anyway I would've got fifty right
you are the below four words are
opposites or nearly opposite pick those
two opposites a cool SC atoll in
Trickett obvious and tempted cool it's
all about you know taking out the words
you don't know that's what I wanted you
to do that quickly I asked oh I think
that is a form of grain they used to
farm in the fields back in 1926
intricate and obvious I'm gonna do a
queasy obstacle and obvious and no I
didn't just get that answer cuz I don't
know what ecclesiastical means or tepid
means yeah I wonder if they did have
classes back in the day they're like
okay here's your next cigarette problem
SAT and all the people who come together
to make it realize that time is changing
really fast honestly thank goodness I
did not have to take this test I promise
I did write better on the real test they
would awarded them differently I
probably would have got the better
answers but what was my score equivalent
to like what college would I've gotten
into with that percentage
[Music]